we just got confirmation from Mark
German that a new set of airpods pro is
coming in just a couple of months in
September probably alongside the iPhone
15. and this is usually where I tell you
guys to stop buying airpods right now
don't buy them because a new set is
coming but actually I've been thinking
about it and I've changed my mind so
let's dig into this report apparently
according to Mark German he's also kind
of confirming what minchiko said before
we are expecting new airpods Pro with
USBC instead of lightning on the bottom
now Ming shukuo was not sure if there
would be any other features or not but
Mark gurman is saying it's basically
going to be the only difference So
airpods Pro 2 like we have right now but
with USBC instead of lightning now
usually that would get me very very
excited because finally apple is getting
rid of that lightning port and you
specifically just so much more useful
especially it says there's the iPad Pro
with USBC basically all of the iPads and
we also have the MacBooks with usb-c
ports which is amazing but I realized
something about my airpods Pro 2
experience over the last few months
since I've had it the really special
thing about the earpods Pro 2 is that
you can charge it now with an Apple
Watch charger as well as macsafe now let
me tell you guys I've been using Mac
safe charging and Apple watch charging
exclusively on my earpods so even if a
new set comes out with USBC I'm
literally not gonna use it so I don't
need it and I'm going to tell you guys
as well if you're thinking about
upgrading there's really no point
because wireless charging is really the
future it is so convenient to just plop
this on your max save charger when you
don't need to charge your iPhone or even
the Apple watch charger now you don't
need the port anymore I mean I would
think Apple would just get rid of this
port honestly because the wireless
charging works so well you leave it on
your nightstand for the night and it
just works and that's why this time
around I'm not telling you guys to stop
and hold off because in reality the
airpods pro are on a three year Tick
Tock cycle where it takes three years to
upgrade because the original airpods Pro
were released three years before these
ones and I think it's going to be the
same thing again so don't expect any
major upgrades this September when the
iPhone 15 finally switches to USBC and
we get USBC earpods Pro 2. we might even
be able to upgrade just the case itself
if you really want to but guys just use
the wireless charging it works so well
now Mark gurman also mentioned that
there could be some new sensors
including temperature detection where we
within your ear canal it can actually
measure your temperature more accurately
than you can with even the Apple watch
because apparently the sensors are going
to work super well so that's going to be
coming but definitely not until the
airpods Pro 3 close to three years from
now there were also talks about the
earpods light but honestly I feel like
those might just be the Beats brand that
we got which apple is going to focus on
their lower end products as the Beats
brand airpods as the higher end so we
might not even see those we honestly
just got airpods three so we're not
going to see an upgrade to the regular
airpods for a while as well so if you're
looking for airpods just buy them right
now who cares about USBC just use the
wireless charging but even further than
that if you're thinking about getting
airpods don't even wait for the airpods
Pro 3 or the earpods 4. these things are
absolutely
incredible honestly the sound quality
the noise reduction is so good that I've
stopped using my airpods Max that I
bought a couple of years ago the sound
quality on those was amazing The Sound
Stage spatial audio just sounded so good
but these things honestly sound just as
good in some cases they sound a little
bit better which is so shocking that
Apple was able to do this without
Wireless lossless audio support which I
thought was coming to the airpods Pro 2
but apparently it didn't but it still
sounds so good so I'm telling people
don't buy the earpods Max don't wait for
the airpods max to just buy the earpods
Pro 2. they sound absolutely amazing and
I love that it has the new speaker on
the bottom for locating it if you can't
find it this is literally saved me from
losing it because this works well and
you can hear it but getting back to the
USBC subject I've realized something
about my iPhone as well I use max safe
almost exclusively for charging at work
I have my charging stand it's always
there facing me and it works so well and
surprisingly my battery health is still
so good after using wireless charging
and with the iPhone 15 we know that it's
going to switch over to USBC which is
going to be awesome and I think it's
going to be great for transferring a lot
of files like video files but honestly
for charging I still don't think the
usb-c port matters magsafe is the way to
go and I'm so happy that Apple went with
it and it's working so well especially
in the car with the charging Mount that
you hook up onto your AC vents that
works incredibly well I personally think
that apple is gonna ditch ports
altogether in 2026 with their major
redesign because macsafe works so well
and they're going to add data transfer
support to the actual macsafe Puck using
some crazy technology in their patents
so in reality does USBC matter for the
iPhone and for the airpods yes it'll be
a little bit nicer because we're finally
ditching lightning in the very slow
speeds but macsafe Wireless is the way
to go especially with the airpods that
now supports Apple watch charging as
well just so many options with charging
these things so basically if you're
looking for airpods go ahead order them
right now don't wait you're not going to
miss out with that USBC Port you'll be
totally just fine with these now in
terms of when you should actually
upgrade in the future because these
things are just so good I think it's
going to require a major redesign or a
major feature to be added because it
basically has everything you need it
sounds amazing with these ones right
here I think it might be the new leaks
for the touch display that we saw with
some patents a couple of weeks ago or
months ago that was actually very
interesting because with that touch
display you would be able to change your
volume your music audio controls other
things even liking new albums and songs
directly from the airpods case itself so
I'm gonna leave some links down in the
description below and the pin comment to
the latest sales with these airpods Pro
2 because they do go outside still for
very good prices so hopefully you enjoy
this video and if you have some thoughts
about maxsafe use C lightening these
ports everything leave them down in the
comment section below and if you enjoyed
the video click the circle above for
more videos like this one definitely
check out one of those two right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
foreign
[Music]